comment sont mes cheveux fort tellement
fort il soulèverait une voiture écrasant
un bébé s'il ne fallait absolument je ne
te l'entendre dit l'éducation c'est
notre avenir sont les agriculteurs qui
font tenir ce pays de mon banquier les
femmes soldats les opérateurs philippe à
deux tours de poule sont ceux qui font
tenir ce pays doit vous salamat comme
aurait dit ça sur un cinquième mandat au
congrès simplement en s'inscrivant comme
candidat c'est l'un des avantages quand
on est seul en lice
allez je vous gribouille jamais s'il
faut tirer ou pousser salut tu sues suis
là j'en ai rêvé toute ma vie présenter
aux élections
vous vous lancez contre notre député au
4e mandat comment comptez vous faire re
dit moi ça maintenant je me présente
pour être député on va nous observer à
la loupe une voix t-il quelque chose à
nous confier blasphémé contre est due à
l'école bientôt je suis allé à la mini
ferme et la chèvre les schémas saucisses
le petit mec est un barjot je l'explosé
ce guignol
on a du pain sur la planche navré de
vous le dire mon ami je vais vous êtes
graphique on est une baudruche une
baudruche conflit avec ses propres
taille d'une vache fric tu veux me
lancer ta maman est comme un aspirateur
on la branche elle avale tout et ensuite
on l'a four dans le placard ses savoirs
dit plus haut ça suffit
à washington c'est le bazar comment on
dit c'est le bazar on les brûle pas là
comme dans quel camp tu veux une guerre
sainte micro toulouse non d'un moine
chinois qui se perd rien ne se crée dans
le fion vers anvers
je refuse de perdre et c'est moi qui
gagnerait
ce chien sacrément
marty riggins que ce que vous avez là
une arbalète aux messieurs
on a des bébés embrasser simon
embrassades de baby mérité
via de boxer un bébé
qui se soucie de ma main après ce coup
contre la mâchoire d'acier de ce
redoutable bébé